[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناو
اياتنا تجاه شعوبنا والعالم
السعوديه تؤكد دعمها سياده الدول وتقول ان
التحديات العالميه تتطلب تعزيز التعاون
طيران الرياض يستعرضه يتى وتصميمه برحله
استعراضيه هي الاولى في سماء العاصمه
السعوديه
اتفاقيه سعوديه صينيه لبناء اكبر مصنع
للصلب في الرياض بطاقه تصل الى 800 الف طن
سنويا
في الرابعه
الجمارك السعوديه تحبط محاوله تهريب 480
الف حبه مخدره مخباه بين اطنان الاقمشه
والبيئه السعوديه تطلق اليه للتعامل مع
الظواهر والازمات الجويه بالشكل والوقت
المناسبين
اكد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان في كلمته بالاجتماع الوزاري
الثاني بين الدول العربيه والدول
الباسيفيك حرص المملكه على دعم سياده
الدول واستقلالها وحل النزاعات في المنطقه
وفقا للمبادئ الدوليه والقرارات الشرعيه
انطلاقا من مسؤولياتنا تجاه شعوبنا
والعالم وواجبنا نحو مستقبل الاجيال
القادمه تؤكد المملكه على دعمها المستمر
لمبادئ الشرعيه الدوليه الراميه للحفاظ
على الامن والسلم الدوليين وتعزيز التعاون
المشترك المبني على اسس الاحترام
المتبادله للسياده في الدول واستقلالها
وحل النزاعات بالطرق السلميه وعدم التصعيد
واللجوء الى القوه او التعديل بها
وبناء على هذا الاساس فاننا نستحضر دائما
واولا قضيه رئيسيه القضيه الفلسطينيه التي
نسعى منذ عقود لايجاد الحل العادل والشامل
لها وفق قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه ومبادره
السلام العربيه
لقيت زياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكان الى
السعوديه ولقائه ولي العهد السعودي لقيت
صدن واسعا في الاعلام الامريكي حيث دعا
كاتب في الواشنطن تايمز الامريكيه كيفن
الى دعوه الامير محمد بن سلمان الى القاء
كلمه في الكونجرس لتكون فرصه للشعب
الامريكي الى الاستماع الى رؤيته حول
المنطقه واستشهد ايضا كاتب اخر في نيويورك
تايمز براي احد الباحثين في معهد دول
الخليج العربيه في واشنطن بين الرياض او
بان الرياض واشنطن تحاولاني اداره التحول
في العلاقه الى واقع متعدد الاقطاب جديد
لقد زياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
الاخيره الى السعوديه اهتماما بالغا من
اعراب الامريكي والدولي والتي اعتبرها
خطوه امريكيه جديده لاعاده بناء الثقه في
العلاقات بين الرياض و واشنطن الكاتب
الايراني الامريكي والبروفيسور في جامعه
جورج تاون روب سبحاني طالبه في مقال له
على واشنطن تايمز البيت الابيض بالبحث عن
شركاء اقوياء لمواجهه التحديات العالميه
الدائمه الكاتب سبحاني وفي مقال له قال
بان هناك خمسه عوامل تلخص دوافع الامير
محمد بن سلمان وهي حبه واعتزازه
المتبادلين للسعوديه وشعبها اضافه الى
رغبته في تلك لبلاده ولشعبه وثالثا تحويل
المملكه وشعبها الى قوه تغيير ايجابيه
عالميه الكاتب اضاف بالتزام ولي العهد
السعودي الثابت بتمكين النساء السعوديات
اضافه الى حبه الابتكار
السابق في الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه
نورمان رول سيد نورمان اهلا وسهلا بك معي
في نشره الرابعه اولا الى اي مدى يمكن
الربط
نتائج زياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
للسعوديه ولقائه بالامير محمد بن سلمان مع
هذا الصدى الواسع الذي وجدناه في الاعلام
الامريكي في قراءتهم وتحليلاتهم لهذه
الزياده
منذ اكثر من سته او سبعه اشهر والعلاقات
الامريكيه السعوديه تطورت بشكل كبير هنا
لك كم كبير جدا من العمل خلف الكوارث من
قبل الدبلوماسيه الطرفين والذي تلقى
التغطيه اعلاميه قليله الا ان التقدم كان
مستقرا وقاد ذلك لزياره ليس فقط وزير
الخارجيه بل كذلك زياره المستشاره ان
القومي سلفا هذه الزيارات تركز على مسائل
استراتيجيه وهذه كلمه كبيره غالب ما
تستخدم
ولكنها تختلف عن اسلوب التعامل مع العديد
من الدول لان علاقتنا مع السعوديه تدور
حول التحول الطاقه وتحول المنطقه
والانخراط الاقليمي كل هذه
الملفات كبيره جدا وذات اهميه بالغه لكن
على الارض ما هي نتائج الملموسه التي يمكن
النظر اليها الان
لهذه الزيارات المتعدده لمسؤولين امريكيين
على اكثر من مستوى في اعاده ربما حاله
الدفء للعلاقه بين الرياض والشنطه
دبلوماسيه ستستمر بكونها هادئا ولا اعتقد
ان المشاهدين سيرون الكثير منها لانها
تجري خلف الكواليس ولكن سيكون هنالك
التفاعل بين الشركات الطاقه حول مساله
خاصه بسكك الحديد والطاقه الخضراء
والدبلوماسيه المستمره حول اليمن والسودان
وحتى الشراكات العسكريه
انخراطي جيشنا لضمان حره الملاحه في البحر
الاحمر والبحر العربي عبر العرب وهذه مهمه
جدا لتجاره العالم فمثل هذه الاحداث ستحصل
وتستمر وهذا ما يحصل في العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه عاده لا نرى
المسائل التكتيكيه
وهي لا تتلقى الكثير من التغطيه الاعلاميه
احد الكتب في صحيفه نيويورك تايم تعتقد
كان قد يعني حتى الاداره الامريكيه على
التقرب كذلك من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
من الامير محمد بن سلمان شخصيا وتوجيه
الدعوه له في الكونجرس الامريكي لالقاء
خطاب ربما الحديث عن رؤيته لمستقبل
السعوديه ومستقبل منطقه الى اي مدى مثل
هذا الراي يمكن ان يحرك مثلا
الكونجرس بتبني مثل هذه الخطوه وما مدى
اهميتها وتاثير
هو مؤسسه سياسيا وستكون هناك الكثير من
المسائل السياسيه المرتبطه هذا القرار
ولكن جدير بالذكر انه خلال الاشهر القليله
كان هنالك عدد من الزيارات على مستوى مجلس
الشيوخي والنواب الى السعوديه والمنطقه
وهنا المنطقه لها اهميه في هذا السياق
الوزير التقى بوزراء خارجيه المجلس دول
مجلس التعاون الخليجي على سبيل المثال
فهذه ليست فقط مساله سعوديه ولكن
ايضا ان كاتب هذا المقال يعكس ما به
الكثير من الامريكيين وهو ان السعوديه تحت
قياده الملك سلمان وولي العهد محمد بن
سلمان ووزرائهم يعملون جاهدين لتحويل
المنطقه
وباتجاه ايجابي ويجب ان يشارك في ذلك ويجب
ان نعمل معهم ونتعرف كيفيه ندعمهم وما
الفوائد التي كنت تدر على العالم من هذا
التحول الرائع ما الواقع السياسي الذي
تريد واشنطن بلورته في المنطقه وترى ان
هناك دورا مهما سعوديا في مستقبل سيدنا
لا شك بانها دوله عادائيه ولم تغير
الماضيه ولكن يجب ان نتجنب حربا تقليديه
ستدمرك كثيرا من طموحات المنطقه وتكلف
حياه الكثيرين وتؤثر الاقتصاد العالم
فمعالجه هذه المساله وكذلك نزاع اليمن
والعمل على تقليل
امدي ازمه وصراع
السودان مثل هذه التفالات التي سنشهدها
وهذا ايضا سيكون له اثر على مسيوخ الذي
يراقبوا هذه المساله عن قربك ويثمر الدوره
تلعب السعوديه وشركاء اخرين في المنطقه
لماذا تصر الولايات المتحده الان على
ملف التطبيع في العلاقه بين السعوديه
واسرائيل وجعله اولويه الملفات في كل
الزيارات كما تنشر في كثير من وسائل
الاعلام في هذا التوقيت يعني ما صلح
الامريكيه المصلحه للمنطقه والى اي مدى
يمكن يعني
ان تقدم الولايات المتحده اثمان مثل هذا
الاتفاق للمملكه العربيه السعوديه المنطقه
سيدنا
يجب ان نكون حاضرين في طريقتنا لوصلها
المساله
لا تلح او تصير ولم تجعلها اولويه قصوى
ولكن من المنطقي ان يكون الانخراط
الدبلوماسي بدون كافه الاطراف الاساسيين
في المنطقه سيروج التجاره والعلاقات بين
الشعوب والقرارات حول المسائل الشائكه
الفلسطيني الاسرائيليه مضت السبعون او 80
عام من دون علاقات وكيف نجح ذلك وكيف كانت
ترهل العالم هل نحن سبعين وثمانين عاما
اخرى لنفس الوضع هل سيجرى ذلك بالمصلحه
للشعوب المنطقه واشنطن
على حدوث ذلك ولكن من المنطقين ان نتحدث
بهذا الشكل واذا كان بامكان العالم العربي
يتحدث مع ايران وبشار الاسد فالتحدث مع
الحكومه الاسرائيليه او اطراف اخرين فهذه
الدبلوماسيه الشائعه والمنطقيه وسيحصل ذلك
عندما يكون الوقت مناسبا للمنطقه
وهذا القرار ليس بوسالات متحده تاخذه ولكن
نستطيع ان نشجع عليه شكرا جزيلا لك من
واشنطن المسؤول السابق بالاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه نورمال
نذهب مباشره الان لمتابعه حفل تدشين
الهويه البصريه لطيران الرياض
ورئيس مجلس اداره صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه في شهر مارس الماضي يؤسس طيران
الرياض لحقبه جديده في قطاع الطيران لتكون
مدينه الرياض
بوابه للعالم ووجهه عالميه للنقل والتجاره
والسياحه نحن واياكم نرى الان امامنا على
المدرج الفئه الاولى من التصميم الخارجي
لاسطول طائرات طيران الرياض وهي تتالق
تتالق بلون زهر الخزامى والتي تعكس ترحيبا
وكرم ارض المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بزوارها
نتشرف بعد قليل بكلمات افتتاحيه من اصحاب
السمو والمعالي والسعاده التي شرفت هذا
الحفل لكن قبل ذلك اسمحوا لنا بعرض هذا
المقطع القصير والذي يحكي لنا بدايه هذا
الناقل الوطني الجديد من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والذي سيعيد صياغه مستقبل
الطيران والسفر في هذا الفيديو
[موسيقى]
المدينه التي ترسم للحياه افقا جديدا
تعيد صياغه كل ما نعرفه عن تجربه السفر
التقنيات
واعلى معايير كرم الضيافه الاصيله عبر
رحلات
نعيش معها مستقبل السفر باجمل اشكاله نقدم
لكم ناقلا جويا بمقاييس عالميه ياخذنا
لاكثر من مئه وجهه بحلول عام 2030
ليربط العالم بمدينه الغد الرياض
[موسيقى]
طيران الرياض
المستقبل يبدا هنا
الان نرحب بصاحبه السمو الاميره هيفاء بنت
محمد ال سعود نائب وزير السياحه وعضو مجلس
اداره طيران الرياض
السلام عليكم جميعا
اصحاب المعالي والسعاده صراحه اليوم يعني
اقول لكم مبروك لنا جميعا الطياره موجوده
هنا السرعه اللي احنا مشينا فيها ونشوف
الطياره موجوده امامنا بالجراه في اللون
والجراه في التنفيذ وهذا يعكس الجراه في
طموحنا احنا اليوم طموحنا عاليه لما نتكلم
على رؤيه 2030 رؤيتنا في السياحه مئه
مليون سائح
ورؤيتنا في الطيران 330 مليون راكب بحلول
عشرين ثلاثين اليوم هذا كله نشوفه يتحقق
بطيران الرياض
الناقل الجوي الجديد في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه واليوم بس حابه اقول لكم مبروك
علينا جميعا واليوم بعد احنا نحلم اليوم
احنا نشوف واليوم احنا ننفذ مبروك
[تصفيق]
شكرا لصاحبه السمو الاميره هيفاء ال سعود
الان نرحب بمعالي المهندس صالح الجاسر
وزير النقل وخدمات اللوجستيه كلمات
السلام عليكم مساكم الله بالخير
ومبارك لنا جميعا حقيقه بالمملكه وفي
صناعه الطيران في صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه بالرياض واهلها وزائريها هذا اليوم
الاستثنائي
لفجر جديد في صناعه الطيران اليوم هي
خطوات عمليه ثابته سمو سيدي ولي العهد
يعيد صياغه صناعه الطيران بالتاكيد في
المملكه وربما في العالم
مباركتي لكم جميعا
وهذه خطوه يتبعها خطوات باذن الله والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
شكرا لكم علي الوزير الان رحبوا معي
بالاستاذ يزيد الحميد نائب المحافظ ورئيس
الاداره العامه للاستثمارات في الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا في صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه السعودي
شكرا اصحاب السمو واصحاب المعالي اصحاب
السعاده يعني احب نبارك للجميع حقيقه في
المنظومات الحكوميه اللي اليوم شاركه
معانا في صندوق سمارات العامه كانوا خير
داعمين لاطلاق فجر جديد ان شاء الله
بصناعه الطيران في المملكه طبعا هذا
امتداد لجهود جهود صندوق استثمارات العامه
في اطلاق قطاعات جديده كما يعلم الجميع
قطاع الطيران هو احد القطاعات
الاستراتيجيه في صندوق الاستثمارات العامه
ليس يكون عندنا ناقل وطني جديد وانما في
البنى التحتيه وكذلك جميع الخدمات
المسانده لقطاع الطيران في المملكه وهذا
بالتاكيد بالشراكه مع جميع القطاعات
الحكوميه الداعمه على راسها طبعا منظومه
النقل برئاسه معالي الاستاذ صالح الجاسر
والاخوان في الهيئه العامه للطيران المدني
برئاسه معالي الاستاذ عبد العزيز الدعيرج
والمنظومه كانوا داعمين بالاضافه الى
شركائنا خاصه من القطاع الخاص لنعتقد
حيكونون مكمل ومكمل اساسي لنجاح استثمارات
الصندوق في قطاع الطيران طبعا يمكن بس لو
اعطي بعض الارقام احنا نستهدف في طرائن
الرياض الى الوصول لاكثر من 100 وجهه
عالميه ان شاء الله من مدينه الرياض والتي
هي طبعا تخدم شريحه كبيره سواء على القطاع
السياحي او على قطاع الاعمال وبالنسبه
للمستويات التي سيتم تقديمها هو سيتم
تقديم
الطيران
باعلى درجات الراحه والرفاهيه مع المحافظه
على تجربه السفر الفريده للضيوف طبعا احب
اختم طبعا اشكروا جميع المشاركين على
راسهم فريق العمل حقيقه هو هذا العمل يمكن
من سنتين ونص بدا واليوم الحمد لله نشوف
الطياره واقفه ومثل ما ذكر رئيس التنفيذي
في التصريحات سابق الربع الاول ان شاء
الله من عام 25 بيكون التشغيل التجاري
الرسمي باذن الله وكلنا ان شاء الله نحظى
باول رحله ان شاء الله تقدر شكرا شكرا لكم
مبروك
شكرا للاستاذ يزيد واخيرا نرحب بالسيد
طوني دوجلاس الرئيس التنفيذي لطيران
الرياض
اصحاب السعاده والمعالي ايها السيدات
والساده
استطيع ان اقدم كلمتي حتى من دون يتباي
صوت
السكوت التام
لانه بلا شك هذا يوم مميز لنا جميعا في
عائله طيران الرياض
ولكنها لحظات التامليه
خاصه منذ 78 عاما من تاريخ الطيران المدهش
والبعث الفقر في المملكه كتاب التاريخ
اكثر من مجرد كتاب هنالك مجلدات
من الانجازات المميزه والخاصه اتمنى ان
يكون لهذا الفصل الصفحه في هذا الكتاب
كتاب التاريخ ولكن طيران الرياض هو جزء من
هذا الفصل الاول
قرارنا كبيرا لتقديم واحده من هذه
الطائرات الى المملكه ليظهر للمواطنين
اولا قبل بقيه العالم
في الاسبوع القادم في
معرض الطيران باريس
الاجتماعي عندما خرج من الورشه في
واستطيع ان اشارككم بعض الاشاعات كلنا نحب
الاشاعات في اسطنبول الكل كان يعتقد ان
عملنا ذلك عن قصد في اليوم الاول
تجتمع معا
لقد تسببت بصخب كبيره جدا في صناعه
الطيران لماذا لان هذا ما لم يكونوا
يتوقعه
ويستحق
خطابا
لتفسير معناها
القصد هو حامل شركه طيران الوطنيه الى
جانب خطوط جويه السعوديه
الخطوط الجويه الوطنيه على السعوديه وبكل
فخر لتربط المملكه بالعالم والعالم
بالمملكه
ولتقدم نفسها بشكل
على انها شبكه معاصره ورقميه في اسلوب
تقديمها لاضيافه السعوديه
باعلى المعايير
سنخرج بعد قليل لنقف عن الطائره ونتمنى ان
تشاركون ايماننا بان هذه طائره رائعه
وجميله سوف تعبر بشكل رائع جدا عن علامه
التجاريه وعن الطيران الرياض في اي مكان
في العالم سوف تتميز بلا شكل عن كل
الطائرات سواء كانت في شانغهاي او مطاري
هيترو في لندن او مطار جوني في نيويورك
والجميع سيرونها على انها هي امتداد لهذه
العلامه التجاريه نيابه عن المملكه والى
العالم اجمعان الشرف الذي يشعر به
والتواضع الذي يملانا في لعب جزء صغير
ونتمنى نكون عاما في استراتيجيه التنوع
الاقتصادي للمملكه عبر قوه الوصول الى
العالم هو شيء لا ناخذه بيسر وحقيقه انكم
اخذتم من وقتكم الثمين اصحاب السموع
والمعالي سيدات والساده لمشاركتنا هذا
الحدث اليوم هو شيء
يشعرنا بالتواضع شكرا لكم جزيلا
هذه الاولى وهذه الثانيه
[تصفيق]
حتى انت جاري
العمل بهذا التوقيت المثالي
ولكن
سيكون هنالك تقديم ثاني حتى اكثر جمالا من
هذا لاحقا هذا العام
وهنا نحاول ان نبني هذا الخطاب وننشرهم
يبعث التشويق
والحماسات عندما نبدا في عملنا في مطلع 20
حينها او الى ذلك الوقت نتمنى لك فرصا
عديده لنا الاحتفال بها مثل هذه اصحاب
السمو والمعاليب ايها السيدات والساده مره
اخرى شكرا لكم جزيلا
[تصفيق]
شكرا للسيد توني دوجلس من هنا من هنا يبدا
المستقبل يوم تاريخي في قطاع الطيران
والنقل الجوي في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وفي العالم الان ندعو معالي وزير النقل
والخدمات اللوجستيه مع لرئيس الهيئه
العامه للطيران المدني ونائب محافظ
رئيس التنفيذي ايضا كذلك لطيران الرياض
لتسليم الرخصه التجاريه للناقل الجوي
الجديد طيران الرياض
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا كان هذا حفل الهويه البصريه لطيران
الرياض اليوم ايضا كان قد حلقت طيران
الرياض في سماء العاصمه السعوديه قبل ايام
من اول المشاركه دوليه للناقل الجديد
الجوي في معرض باريس الجوي والذي ينطلق
الاثنين المقبل قامت الطائره بالتحليق على
ارتفاع منخفض في سماء الرياض مرورا من
ابرز معالمها مثل مركز الملك عبد الله
المالي والبوليفارد وكشف طيران الرياض عن
تصميمه هويته وعن الفئه الاولى من التصميم
الخارجي للاسطول طائراته تخطى الطيران
الرياض لربط العاصمه السعوديه باكثر من
100 وجهه حول العالم وتعد شركه طيران
الرياض ومطار الملك سلمان الدولي ضمن احدث
استثماراتي صندوق الاستثمارات العامه في
قطاع الطيران الهاتف لرفع الاستدامه
لمنظومه قطاع الطيران وتعزيز التنافسيه
عالميا
ابتداء من العام 20 25 يبدا طيران الرياض
التحليق عبر اصوله المكون من 72 طائره
بوينج لاينر من طراز تسعه
787 ليخلق تجربه جديده في مجال النقل
الجوي على المستوى الاقليمي والدولي طيران
الرياض المملوك بالكامل لصندوق
الاستثمارات السعوديه يهدف الى الوصول
لاكثر من مئه وجهه حول العالم بحلول عام
2030 شركه طيران الرياض مشاهدينا ستكون
اولا ناقله في العالم ذات طابعين رقمي في
خدمه العملاء وتجربه المسافرين حيث ستقدم
الشركه خدمات كامله من فئه خمسه نجوم
بجوده عالميه عبر رحلاتها المميزه كما
تهدف الشركه التي ترتبط باسم العاصمه
الرياض الى ربط السعوديه بالعالم والعالم
بالسعوديه وتعزز حضور الرياض على الخريطه
الاستثماريه العالميه طيران الرياض كذلك
سيخدم اهداف السعوديه السياحيه لتسعى الى
استقطاب مائه مليون زائد بحلول العام
عشرين ثلاثين كما ستشكل نقطه ربط بين
العالم وجهات ومشاريع السعوديه الكبرى مثل
اليوم والبحر الاحمر والعلى اضافه الى
الدرعيه شركه طيران الرياض مشاهدينا ستعمل
كذلك على تعزيز مكانه السعوديه
الاستراتيجيه لتربط بين قارات العالم
الثلاث اسيا واوروبا وافريقيا من خلال رفع
طاقه الاستيعابيه لخدمات النقل والشحن
والخدمات اللوجستيه كما سترفع الشركه
مشاهدينا الاستدامه الماليه لمنظومه قطاع
الطيران وتعزز تنافساتها عالميا تحقيقا
لمستهدفات رؤيه السعوديه
2030 وحول تاثير الشركه على الاقتصاد
السعودي من المتوقع ان يسهم طيران الرياض
مشاهدينا في نمو الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
غير النفطي مما يصل الى 75 مليار ريال
اضافه الى خلق اكثر من 200 الف فرصه عمل
مباشره وغيري مباشره
اطياف البنفسجي تحلق للمره الاولى في سماء
الرياض طيران الوطني الجديد طيران الرياض
الذي يكتسي اللون البنفسجي حيث يمثل لون
ازهار الخزامى الذي اعتمدته السعوديه لونا
رسميا لاستقبال ضيوفها اما تصميم شعار
العلامه التجاريه فالشكل البيضاوي المحيط
بالشعار يمثل نافذه الطائره باعتبار هذا
الطيران نافذه السعوديه الجديده على
العالم اما الخط المائل فيرمز لجناح
الطائره والخط العربي كان له نصيب ايضا من
هويه الطيران الجديد
وبعد الاعلان عن تاسيسه في مارس الماضي
بدا الطيران الرياض الناقل الجوي الوطني
الجديد اعماله الاداريه في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض استعدادا لانطلاق اولى
رحلاته في عام 2025 لاكثر من 100 وجهه حول
العالم التفاصيل مع غاده الفهد
بشر طيران الرياض اعمالها الاداريه في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض بكوادر وخبرات
محليه ودوليه من مختلف التخصصات مؤهلين
للتعامل مع احدث تقنيات في عالم صناعه
الطيران تحدث ترامب الرياض الى تعزيز موقع
الرياض كعاصمه للمملكه وكذلك تعزيز مكانه
الرياض ومنظومه السياحه الداخليه وتتناغم
هويتها مع التراث الوطني اللي هو لون
الخزانه
من المنتظر ان يساهم الطيران الجديد في
توفير نحو 200 الف فرصه عمل مباشره وغير
مباشره بحلول 2030 في حين تلقى ما يزيد عن
400 الف طلب توظيف الى الان قامت باستقطاب
العديد من المهارات الشافه المتواجده في
داخل الرياض وخارج الرياض حيث ان تواجده
بشركه مثل طيران الرياض
فرصه كبيره للعديد من الشباب والشابات
كونها طيران ناشئ بهذا المستوى وقتنا
الحالي شيء نادر ان الواحد يكون جزء منه
اضافه الى ذلك
التطوير المهني والثقافه اللي قاعد يصير
للشباب والشابات في الشركه عن طريق انهم
قاعدين يتدربون ويشتغلون مع افضل الخبرات
الموجوده في مجال الطيران حول العالم
ستنطلق اولى الرحلات من الرياض الى اكثر
من 100 وجهه حول العالم في
في مارس الماضي طلب اثنتين وسبعين طائره
بوينج وحصل الطيران الناشئ على الرمز ار
اكس من الاتحاد الدولي للنقل الجوي
لنرى حاليا في اغلب شركات طيران هو
تقديم الخدمات النقل الجوي بشكل تقليدي
طيران الرياض يسعى الى الابتكار تعزيز
تبني احدث التقنيات الرقميه التي توفر
بالتاكيد تجربه سفر فريده من نوعها
للمسافرين فهذه جزئيه مهمه جدا نسعى الى
خلقها عبر جميع محطات ومراحل سفر ضيوفنا
عبر مثلا رحلات طيران الرياض طيران الرياض
سيكون اول طيران في العالم يقدم تصميمين
مختلفين لاسطوله تصميم مستوحى من الوان
زهره الخزامى الغطاء الطبيعي الذي يغطي
صحاري المملكه خلال فصل الربيع واخر يحمل
مدلولات مستمده من الثقافه السعوديه سيتم
الكشف عنه في وقت قريب غدا الفهد العربيه
الرياء
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الرابع ايضا مستمره فيها بعد قليل
نحو اربعه الاف حاجه يمني عبروا منفذ
الوديع الحدودي حتى له والعربيه توثق
اجراءات العبور
اهلا بكم من جديد يتواصلوا توافد الحجاج
اليمنيين على منفذ الوديعه الحدودي مع
السعوديه حيث استقبل المنفذ حتى الان
حوالي 4000 يمني قدموا عبر المنفذ ومن
المتوقع عبور 19 الف حاج يمنيه عبر المنفذ
الذي تم تجهيزه ليضل مفتوحا حتى نهايه شهر
ذي القعده الجري
[موسيقى]
المنفذ الوديعه على الحدود السعوديه
اليمنية نتابع مع موفد العربيه احمد باجات
احمد مرحبا بك
4000 حاج حتى الان يمني عبروا هذا المنفذ
ان كان هناك من معلومات اكثر حول
الاجراءات التي تتم
نعم بالفعل خالد كما ذكرت اربعه الاف ربما
يزيد قليلا عبروا حتى الان منفذ الوديعه
والمنفذ البري الوحيد ما بين الارض
الاراضي اليمنيه والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه نحن الان نقف داخل خيمه التطعيم
واللقاحات هي الخيمه الاولى التي ينزل
اليها الحجيج من الحافلات يتوجهون في
البدايه لهذه الخيمه ثم بعد ذلك يتوجهون
للخيمه التاليه وهي خيمه الجوازات التي
كنا فيها معك في مباشر سابق كما تشاهد
هؤلاء الاطباء يقفون في انتظار نزول
الحجيج من الحافلات قبل قليل هؤلاء الحجيج
جميعهم اخذوا اللقاحات هناك اللقاحات
اللقاح خاص بالحمى الشوكيه وبعض اللقاحات
الاخرى يتم التاكد من ان الجميع رجالا
ونساء اخذوا هذه اللقاحات ومن ثم يتم
التوجه الى
صاله الجوازات حيث ايضا يقضون بعض الوقت
وقت قصير ليس بالكثير هناك محاولات
للتسهيل على هؤلاء الحج اج الذين قدم
بعضهم لمده في رحله من من مدينته الى
الحدود السعوديه حوالي يوم كامل وربما
بعضهم اخذ يومين دعني اتحدث مع احد احد
الحجيج يعني اتعرف بك
محمد فايز من اي مدينه اتيت من مدينه عزه
كم اخذت منك الرحله حتى وصلت الى هنا اخذت
يوم ونصف
كيف كانت الرحله وكيف كان الاستقبال عندما
جئت الى هنا الرحله كانت شقه يعني في في
عناء السفر الاستقبال كان هنا ممتاز يعني
في العنايه ولقينا في التلقيح في الجوازات
يعني الامور كانت على اكمل يعني صراحه
هل جميع الاشخاص الذين جاؤوا معك من تعز
ولا هناك من محافظات اخرى هناك بعض
الاشخاص يعني نسبه يعني ممكن قد يكون يعني
20%
تعز قدمت من تعز الى عدن ومن ثم من عدن
الى هنا نعم
شكرا نعم يعني هذا مثال للعديد او الالاف
من الحجيج الذين قدموا متوقع ان يعبر ان
يعبر هذا المنفذ تسعه عشر الف حاج حتى
نهايه هذا الشهر شهر ذي القعده وينتهي او
يغلق المنفذ امام حركه الحجيج لان يعني
يكون بدا بعد ذلك شهر ذو الحجه بالطبع
هناك كانت هناك زياره من قبل امير منطقه
نجران الذي جاء وتفقد جميع هذه الخيام
خيمه التطعيم واللقاحات وخيمه الجوازات
وايضا خيمه التي تقدم فيها المعلومات
والوجبات وغيرها وقف وسال الحجاج عن اي
شيء يحتاجونها كانت الامور تسير بصوره
سلسه للغايه حتى اننا سالنا الحجاج الذين
قدموا في سنوات ماضيه قالوا ان الامور هذه
المره اسهل بكثير واكثر ثلاثه شكرا جزيلا
لك احمد العربيه من منفذ الوديعه
في الاخبار المتعلقه بمؤتمر الاعمال
العربي الصيني اعلنت الشركه الصينيه
للهندسه المعماريه انها تجري مفاوضات مع
صندوق الاستثمارات العامه السعودي لبنائي
اكبر مصنع لهياكل الصلب في الرياض بطاقه
الانتاجيه تقدر ب 800 الف طن سنويا وكانت
شركه بوشان للحديد والصلب الصينيه واكبر
منتج للصلب في العالم وقعت في مايو الماضي
اتفاقا مع المملكه لانشاء مصنع للصلب في
مدينه راس الخير
بانتاج يصل الى مليون ونصف المليون طن من
الالواح الفولاذيه السنويه
ايضا على هامش مؤتمر رجال الاعمال العرب
والصينيين المقام في الرياض وقعت وزاره
الاستثمار السعوديه اتفاقيه بقيمه 21
مليار ريال مع شركه هيومن هيورايزنز
الصينيه شركه الصينيه متخصصه في تطوير
التقنيات القياده الذاتيه وتصنيع المركبات
الكهربائيه وتهدف لانشاء مشروع مشترك
لابحاث تطوير وتصنيع وبيع السيارات من هذا
النوع
تمكنت هيئه الزكاه والضريبه والجمارك في
ميناء جده الاسلامي من احباط محاوله تهريب
نحو 480 الف حبه مخدره وذلك بعد العثور
عليها مخباه في ارساليه اقمشه وردت الى
السعوديه عبر الميناء
[موسيقى]
ادركت وزاره البيئه والمياه والزراعه
السعوديه وثيقه اليه للتعامل مع الظواهر
الجويه او وثيقه اليه التعامل مع الظواهر
الجويه التي تهدف لتطوير الخدمات والبرامج
والاليات التي يقدمها المركز الوطني
للارصاد عبر احدث التقنيات والممارسات
للتعامل الامثل مع الظواهر الجويه بشكل
والزمن المناسبه فضلا عن تفسير مراحل
الانذار المبكر والظواهر الجويه المختلف
علاقته العرب بالنجوم علاقه نزليه العرب
باطله الاسماء على النجوم وما زالت شعوب
الارض تنطقها كما نطقها العرب خالد الزر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
علاقه العرب بالنجوم علاقته ازليه فهي من
صميم ارثهم وثقافتهم فهم الذين اسموها وما
زالت شعوب الارض تنطقها كما نطقها العرب
وعن طريقها يعرفون مواقعهم ومواسمهم
وعلامات وبالنجم هم يهتدون وقسموا النجوم
الى قسمين نجوم استدلاليه ونجوم حسابيه
النجوم الحسابيه الثريا واهم النجوم
الاستدلاليه الجدي والطبع ما ينزال غيره
بتبديل مثل الجدي مرساه ليله ونهاره
والحنظله له على شاطئ النيل زادت مرارتها
القديمه مراره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فشروق وغروب الثريا وتوسطها عنان السماء
لها دلائل حسابيه عندهم فشروقها مع شروق
شمس شرقا دليل على بدايه الحر اللي هي
مربعانيه الجير وتوسطها عنان السماء مع
شروق شمس دليل على شده الحر اللي هي جمره
القيل وغيابها مع شروق الشمس غربا دليل
على نهايه الحر وهو موعد لقائها مع الليل
واني لاهون النوم في غير حينه لعل لقاء في
المنام يكون تحدثني الاحلام اني ارىكم فيا
ليت احلام المنامي
يقين
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
وانطلاقا من مسؤولياتنا تجاه شعوبنا
والعالم
السعوديه تؤكد دعمها سياده الدول وتقول ان
التحديات العالميه تتطلب تعزيز التعاون
طيران الرياضي يستعرضه وتصميمه في رحله
استعراضيه هي الاولى في سماء العاصمه
السعوديه
اتفاقيه سعوديه صينيه لبنايه اكبر مصنع
للصلب في الرياض بطاقه تصل ل 800 الف طن
سنويا
الجمارك والسعوديه تحبط محاوله باربع مئه
الف حبه مخدره مخباه بين اطنان اقمشه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات